embarcation sur la rémarde pour ce petit
navigateur et apprentis poètes
on a fait aussi un petit tour en barque
alors le but on n'a pas encore trouvé un
le but étant de reconstituer un poème
avec tous les mots qu'on a pu trouver
sur les bouées plus loin d'autres
familles s'essaie à l'art de la vannerie
alors aujourd'hui je leur fais faire des
petits poissons en osier et puis des
dessous de plat en rotant les choses
simples mais ces techniques de base
voilà de la vannerie les animations
étaient nombreuses pour cette sixième
édition de jardins en fête à la maison
elsa triolet aragon artistes et artisans
investissent les six hectares de la
propriété mais à triolet l'aîné à moscou
et ragon il a vécu à paris donc des gens
de lavera ville de la grande ville et je
peux dire quand ils sont arrivés ici à
saint-arnoult ils ont dit c'est à
triolet qui dit ça à sa soeur est dit
j'avais raté la nature jusqu'à présent
les donc c'est un moment important pour
rejoindre saint-arnoult c'est de
satisloh nîmes de la découverte de la
nature et donc pour nous était important
que cette maison soit aussi à l'image de
cette préoccupation de la nature qui
aujourd'hui prend une place importante
une dizaine de stands et des spectacles
de l'acrobatie dans les arbres et une
immersion des spectateurs dans l'art
ils en ressortent même avec un diplôme
d'expériences artistiques
pour l'instant ça se passe bien nous on
ne rien et on est diplômé et c'est
surtout en fait un des chantres entre
l'artiste et les gens une transmission
vraiment pas un atelier de deux sons de
loisirs une transmission de l'art de
chacun pendant un petit court instant
une journée pour s'évader artistiquement
dans la fraîcheur de ce jardin bucolique
[Musique]
et moi de la terre